I think people burn out because they're
not doing their thing if you ask me to
hang a picture right now on a wall I'd
be burned out by the time I got to the
Hammer
I can literally do this in front of this
audience for the next 48 hours straight
you asked me to go walk a dog I'll be
sleeping within the first second I don't
want to do that so I think the reason
people burn out is because they're not
doing their thing normally people are
not doing their thing because they got
trapped by the money either the chase of
it or they're making and now they're
living within the means of that money
and they're stuck they're Gary I can't
quit my job like you could if you
decided to stop spending the same amount
of money that you spend on yourself you
could sell your house you could but
nobody wants to go backwards meanwhile
they're mentally backwards every day
people are not going backwards
financially moving back in with their
parents selling their ship to be unhappy
their whole lives
do you know what [__] up that is